You ever heard David Beckham speak? It’s like he mouth-sexed a can of helium.
You've heard David Beckham speak. You ever heard David Beckham speak? It’s like he mouth-sexed a can of helium.. I
I am so sorry so so so
Too soon? Yeah, too soon
Tickets for the cup. I can't wait to not watch Italy play the Netherlands. I
Can't stay mad at you Healing hugs. Here we go. Oh God, finally that feels so good. You smell amazing
like cinnamon and manhood. Let's never let go.
No, no. No, we should let's let go of this burden together. Just wonderful. No, okay
What are you apologizing for? Anyway. Well, just the bit in Deadpool with the with voice
Doesn't ring a bell
What did you think I was apologizing for? I mean, there's a list Green Lantern. R.I.P.D
... selfless -terrible- blade Trinity _uff, Boltneck.
DP: BOLTNECK it was a masterpiece!
I know I raised my voice. I lost control, please open up!.